hey guys and welcome to the first
official vlog from Los Angeles damn it
why do you keep hitting that like this
is just gonna be my vlog now so how have
you been so I woke up with an earthquake
today I set my alarm for about 6:45
every morning and pretty much bang on
like I forget was like six little after
6:30 all sudden sugar sugar sugar
everyone thing was shaking so we really
got experience being the first time that
I'm in California I've never had a
earthquake before so that was fun I'm
really happy that happened um but
besides that it was over in like five
seconds so it was weird
so anyway since I've come to Los Angeles
I've been unbelievably busy
I'm literally every single day that I've
gotten up I get up early in the morning
I work on videos from my channel and
then I immediately head out the door to
go do something else last week alone I I
did two days of table flipped with the
game grumps which is super fun and I
can't wait for that to come out and then
I did that thing with jontron cronic an
uberx Renova that i can't tell much
about just yet other than that it's
happening but expect the video to come
out real soon um probably the reason why
I was in a dress again for like the
third time in my life I've worn a lot of
dresses in my life for various reasons
said I'm not gonna explain right now I
don't need to justify myself to you I
can wear a dress if I want to
but anyway the fruits of those labors
should be coming out pretty soon I also
did friendzone obviously I hung out with
cinnamon toast candies a really cool guy
um and I did this thing called rumble
zone which is like we did for the rayman
legends tournament where we all get in a
room with a bunch of other youtubers and
try to win it a kick and i think you'll
find that i performed very admirably
you'll just have to see the results of
it when it comes out but I think you'll
be pleasantly surprised at what I do or
you'll think it's pretty difficult with
my expertise
depending on how expertise ly you think
I play even though I've been keeping
busy I like keeping busy I'm a bit of a
workaholic like some people are think
it's incredible that I get up early in
the morning but that's partly because
the time zones are messing with me and I
think it's earlier or I think it's later
earlier earlier than it really is so
that's fun too but I do want to say that
coming out here is probably shaping up
to be one of the best moves I've ever
made I've already met so many other
youtubers I've been able to hang out
literally hang out with certain people
that I really admire and a youtubers
that I love and watch it's it's been an
honestly incredible experience and and I
don't regret it for a second it's still
weird being out here I was driving at
11:00 p.m. 11 p.m. at night going back
from maker studios and I hit traffic and
I was like oh maybe there was an
accident or there's construction late at
night or something nope there were just
too many people on the road at 11:00
p.m. at night that the roads were
blocked up yeah I was so happy that that
happened then anyway I crawled into bed
when too much sleep woke right back up
and headed out the door again it was
super fun but you know it I like I said
I wouldn't trade it for anything in the
world it's gonna be a really cool
experience also this Thursday I am
heading to Florida for playlist live I
know this is last-minute notice and it's
probably too late for any of you who
weren't already going to get there
I found out last minute so I'm going
apparently and that's happening so um
it's gonna be a big like youtuber thing
there's gonna be a lot of other
youtubers there so I get to talk with
more of them and meet networking show
off how stupid I really am also speaking
of stupid I just
no no not speaking of stupid I just did
youtubers react youtubers react not
stupid I'm stupid that's what the thing
is I know they're never gonna invite me
back again
okay so youtubers react is a lovely
program and I'm so glad that they
invited me on and I had a lot of fun
with it it's not stupid
I'm stupid you know that actually
reminds me sometimes that like eating
when I'm playing a game some people are
or I'll call myself an idiot and some
people are like no we're not stupid and
I'm like I I'm not I'm not intelligently
effectual er I don't word good so you
know I I know that I'm actually quite
intelligent I have a very high IQ but
logically sometimes especially when I'm
playing games it doesn't always work out
in my favor because I'm talking in like
fifty percent of my brain is dedicated
talking so don't worry I completely
understand that I'm not stupid but I
sometimes act very stupid so anyway with
all the stuff that's coming up in the
next few weeks I'm gonna be keeping
myself very busy but don't worry I've
been able to keep my videos as a
priority no matter what I've always
wanted to keep that going even when I
have all this other stuff going on it's
just it's really cool to be keep them so
busy after being in Cincinnati and being
like not near all this stuff and and
some of the production stuff that goes
on and all the professionalism is very
strange to me I'm like I usually make my
videos with like duct tape and a spork
and you guys have all these lighting
equipments and fancy stuff and the crew
and people telling people what to do and
I usually just get in the crime the
camera at like right now and just say
whatever comes my mind so cool huh
anyway
it's been SuperDuper fun enough med
SuperDuper awesome people and the videos
are gonna be super duper awesome
whenever they come out but things kind
of run slower here they try to get this
thing called quality into their videos
that I don't even know what that word
means but they try really hard to make
sure it's high if quality can be high I
have no idea so those would coming out
real soon my videos are still coming out
as regular as I possibly can keep them
if it goes down to one video on a
certain day or like you know two times a
week there's only one video please
understand I'm incredibly busy but I'm
trying to crank the funny out for you
guys as much as I can I'm gonna keep it
up no matter what so thank you all so
much for believing with me thank you so
much for spreading the word about the
channel just um it's amazing we're
almost set to million when we hit 1
million at the end of October and it's
like I've been running this channel for
so long it just tap it happens so
quickly it's such a snowball effect that
I can't keep track of it anymore you
guys are just absolutely amazing in and
I'm so thankful that you believed in me
and I wish I had more of a way to repay
you guys other than just the videos that
I make so I'm gonna keep you on I'm
gonna keep trying to make them better
you know so the fact that I can make
people laugh every day is just
astonishing to me and it's an honor I'm
so happy I can provide some sort of joy
in your lives make you laugh make you
chuckle make you do that reading out
thing with your nose when you see
something kind of funny but not really
but you know either way I'll take
whatever I can get and I'm gonna keep
doing it just for you guys so thank you
guys so much for believing in me and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
hmm bye-bye
you